[Musique]
ouah thierry
type hôtel quel plaisir de t'avoir et
moi je suis content mais tu sais quoi
sans quoi j'aurais jamais tu essaies de
soi je sais pas sur ce soir mais ça me
fait ici ses désirs ça me fait c'est
vrai parce que mon rêve soirée au
cabaret et sans toi je n'aurais jamais
facile que je suis content c'est pour
ces raisons soirée de folie
j'adore cet endroit il n'y a pas
beaucoup de gens qui connaissent mais
j'espère que ce soir ils vont apprécier
l'endroit mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
vous êtes
un samedi soir à pigalle pour le bon
déroulement de la soirée veuillez ne pas
prendre de photos
ne pas filmer les numéros que vous avez
découvrir merci de timbres également au
téléphone portable pour payer
sinon je vous défends sera gueule bande
de cons merci beaucoup et bonne soirée
[Musique]
biya
ap
auj
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça pulse pourtant tout champagne aie
aie
apa
m
palais
[Musique]
ap
non
tha
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle
on va passer un samedi soir ensemble à
pigalle est ce que déjà tout le monde va
bien
ça va être une soirée qui va être
formidable qu'on va vivre ensemble une
soirée placée sous le signe du prestige
sous le signe du chic du glamour voilà
bien sûr du rire aussi mesdames et
messieurs tout feu tout flamme chic et
choc sucré salé voit les vapeurs voilà
j'arrête avec mes expressions des années
50 je suis pas emmanuel macron
bref on va passer ensemble une soirée au
cabaret on est à la nouvelle eve qui est
l'un des lieux les plus mythiques de
paris ça c'est très important de
souligner
vous avez vu je suis beau pas mal
de l'année mais ce que j'ai pris un
styliste voilà un styliste qui date de
l'époque du cabaret alors c'est qu'au
temps du côté de jean dujardin
c'était une réussite il a réussi à
choper un oscar comme ça
moi au mieux je vais réussir à achopper
le numéro de la dame qui a placé juste
ici voilà qu'est tiéné sous raymond
poincaré alors
alors mesdames et messieurs ce soir
c'est une vraie soirée de cabaret qu'on
va passer tous ensemble et qu'on va vous
proposer pour qu'ils ont regardé sur ces
il y aura
il y aura comme
il
et il y aura des dresseurs d'ours en
gpon il aura pas de dresseurs d'ours ce
soir mesdames et messieurs il y aura
avec nous mademoiselle clara morgane
mathieu madénian
[Applaudissements]
trop mal
la troupe de précis la fin du désert
mustapha el atrassi
j'en suis j'en sais
boudeur sageman des dresseurs de rats il
faut l'applaudir mesdames et messieurs
monsieur à m sila
[Applaudissements]
tom 'durrrr' marc wilhem stand up sound
system bien être est gold reef
très drôle mesdames et messieurs j'ai un
cadeau pour vous
pigalle ne serait pas vraiment pigalle
sans ses effeuilleuses je vous demande
d'applaudir extrêmement chaleureusement
mademoiselle tira
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un maximum de monsieur
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir c'est pour toi ça c'est pour toi
ça c'est pour toi et ça c'est pour toi
non ça va les lic
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vas jamais fait chaud et que ton
style c'est dommage pourtant y avait
clara morgane alors mesdames et
messieurs vous pouvez l'applaudir encore
très très fort c'est monsieur eric
antoine
il ya une tradition qui veut que le
parrain ramène toujours un petit cadeau
voilà
jonathan n'ont pas de tradition
d'envoyer un message
un ballon
tu as des cadeaux pour les gens de plus
de trois ans ouais
c'est pas la moyenne d'âge ce soir
on se croirait chez drucker et
qu'est ce que c'est un chien une effet
un clown qui se regardent de faire mieux
c'est une soirée un petit peu interdits
aux moins de 18 ans alors j'ai décidé de
faire une magie un peu interdit peu
moins de 18 ans oh non
alors
qui accueille les alcooliques
si je peux me permettre c'est formidable
mais une bouteille pour 200 ça va être
léger a pas se mentir oui tu as raison
tiens tiens moi ça vous savez où se
cachent les bouteilles ah bon parce que
bien sûr elles n'apparaissent pas comme
ça elles sont cachées auparavant 1 vous
imaginez bien souvent en fait les
magiciens cachent les bouteilles dans la
manche est souvent d'ailleurs on voit
que le corps change de forme au fur et à
mesure du jeu or vous êtes vraiment des
malades
mais en fait là par exemple dans la
manche a fallu tout le monde ça tout de
suite excusez moi elle est où cette
bouteille et lilou la voilà
mesdames et messieurs
merci mon pote merci
les gantois
vous faire un autre tour de magie
si la creuse mais ne peut pas lancer
quelque chose yann l'effeuilleuse elle
est rentrée dans la boîte et eric
antoine hilaire sorti il ya deux trois
mecs je dirai pas qui c'était moi
bon bah bravo
t'es pas content content mesdames et
messieurs le prochain artiste c'est l'un
des meilleurs humoristes sniper du
moment et en même temps c'est un petit
peu le quota de la soirée voilà il
regroupe de handicap les arméniens et
les gens du sud alors d'accord il ya une
seule ch'tis elle est là bas
c'est madame avec les cheveux rouges ça
va régine merci d'être venu on peut
l'appliquer régime fait parler de
notre prochain article
si la voix leila il ya un lien parenté
avec charles aznavour comme tous les
arméniens en même temps ils sont quatre
dans le pays donc fatalement ça non mais
c'est vrai il y en a dans les autres
arménien charles aznavour il ya aussi
kim kardashian et c'est un peu triste
comme pays d'être présentés soit par une
personne âgée soit pas une personne avec
un gros cul
non mais c'est vrai
il est en tournée dans toute la france
avec son spectacle en état d'urgence lui
il a de très bonnes vannes et il a ni
l'un ni l'autre demande de faire un
tonnerre d'applaudissements pour
monsieur mathieu madénian
[Applaudissements]
pour
mais très content d'être ici merci tu
ardisson eric antoine apparemment il ya
le chauffeur hubert est resté
allongé mais ça va
aller bonsoir
la jugent très content d'être ici on m'a
dit tu viens pigalle les souvenirs moi
je vous dis la vérité quand je suis
monté à il ya quinze ans à paris c'est
ici que je suis arrivé j'ai loué 1 20
mètre carré ici juste en bas de la rue
15 mètres carrés loi carrese ça veut
dire je me cognais souvent la tête et en
fait il était petit jeu toucher tous les
murs en même temps dire que je pouvais
pisser et cuisiner je faisais les deux
segments
[Musique]
et est en fait je me suis cassé louer ce
truc là
je vous rappelle je me suis [__] par
la belle hauteur sous plafond c'est le
truc de que la femme de lagence devant
quand tout est pourri un dilemme belle
hauteur sous plafond si je l'avais dire
afin de lancer petit mètre carré un pc
petit musée belle hauteur sous plafond
qu'ai je m'en bats les couilles j'ai pas
de chauves souris qu'est-ce que je fasse
moi j'aime ça je fais pas de trampoline
c'est la belle hauteur soit faussé le
truc qu'on dit qu'on ne sait plus quoi
dire tellement que c'est de la merde
c'est comme quand tu as un comique est
pas marrant et je trouve que je te
montre et
[Musique]
il faut quelqu'un il table sur la
personne de couleur
tu es quand tu as un mec n'est pas
marrant tu toujours à faire alors il
était marrant il a une belle énergie et
bien c'est exactement ça mais sous
plafond je puis ça je me rappelle 1000
euros par mois voir nicole 1000 euros
par mois moi j'ai grandi d'un sud de la
france à côté de perpignan dans un 4 5
mètres carrés réparer ma soeur quand je
jouais le matin j'avais des champs de
vignes à perte de vue avec des chevaux
qui courent et qui me regardait en
souriant
on boit très tôt à perpignan et
et là je ferai un petit truc même mon
père il croyait pas je rappelle qu'à
visiter l'appartement ils étaient là et
ça déconne et mathieu à ça rafael sobis
way home il se fâche c'est un papa c'est
qu'à la châtré mètre carré à paris ces
deux cent mille euros est faite de 5000
euros c'est ce que tu as pour de 5000
euros à perpignan je fais nos perpignan
[Applaudissements]
kg l'assistant partement et je me suis
dit personne ne se bat quoi cet
appartement de 120 m² millions par mois
la femme de lagence m'appelle ce que je
vous raconte est vrai elle me dit
monsieur à dire vous avez une visite
samedi à 8 heures je me suis dit samedi
à 8 heures je restais en pyjama
ce que je dors en pyjama
oublier cette information
et ça sonne chez moi et je vous jure
t'as pas une personne qui déboule tu as
15 personnes en fait une visite à paris
ces 15 personnes âgées reçu 10 morts
pour morges des petits déjeuners donc je
m'installe sur mon canapé mais mon café
mais granola je te jure les mecs passé
dans moi il me regardait comme un singe
dans un zoo
approché pour regarder il est en train
de se nourrir et sont tous avec leur
dossier était là le fameux dossier que
tu donnes à la personne de l'agent si
l'appartement te plaît et la tasse
connard de parisiens qui se bat avec son
ghost in the jar de connacht c'est
allergiques au gluten et là
il y en a ce soir
cinq ans vous étiez voilà c'est pas si
grave
je suis morte et c'est quoi toutes ces
intolérances alimentaires qu'on avait
avant et qu'on n'a plus toutes ses modes
ses com c'est comme les végétariens ya
déficit a rien à la salle vip à la main
gardez-vous forcené ou pas t
végétarienne
ça se voit je te jure parce que tu ris
comme une végétarienne ya rien qui sorte
elad vers 1 et une carotte ça se voit
et une coupe une végétarienne et les
casses couilles je me dis toujours si
une bâche pour et parle elle te dire et
ne mange pas non elle te dirai bout
flotte vaches parce qu'elle te dira
laval
ah oui je sais que tu as au fond tu as
raison on nie que la planète et c'est
sympa une vache mais je te jure avec de
la moutarde c'est tellement bon
y'a pire que toi ya pire que vista ces
gens qui bouffe bio sk des nazis qui
bouffe bio ici
parce qu'un seul truc qu'on apprend avec
le bio c'est que l'animal était mieux
traités d'accord et moi je reste le plus
cruel encore un boulet que toute sa vie
il va courir en liberté et de couple
vous le but et mais vous êtes des
[__] sans déconner moi je mangeais
le poli qui souffrent à l'oratoire ce
cas qu'une pac le bec like et eudis
achève moi
c'est ma théorie je ferme la parenthèse
et là tu as ce connard de parisiens qui
se bat avec l'appartement il vient me
voir je regardais la télé je me rappelle
il prend la télécommande et baisse le
son la télé moi je suis là je fais au et
là il me fait au pardon vous habiter ici
non je suis en visite mais quand je
visite j'utilise toujours le pyjama du
propriétaire je bouffe c'est grenoble à
la con de ta mère c'est 8h15 du matin je
m'en serais de toute ma vie 8h15 matin
evra il me dit est ce que je peux
utiliser vos toilettes et moi je dis oui
mais j'espère qu'il va faire que peace
et
il a tiré trois fois la chasse un sens
des chiottes et là la femme de là j'en
suis dit alors vous laissez votre
dossier et l'aï dit non il est juste
venu chier chez moi à 8h15 du matin un
étranger a chu dans ma demeure cependant
je mangeais les granola en pyjama créa
trial merci d'en écouter très bonne
voiture
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu le spectacle donné par kurt
relais 4 x 6 cm et sa vie est tellement
est-ce que tu connais biquette mais bien
sûr qu'on se connaît son nom c'était
biquettes quand il était petit on
m'avait indiqué tenons mesure deux
mètres il peut sans trop de mal à public
est dans le cosi 48 eu l'appel public
est mal ça fait du cabaret toi je fais
beaucoup de cabaret j'ai commencé il ya
douze ans en cabaret ces deux années
extraordinaires parce que je partageais
la loge avec les cinq danseuses et donc
j'étais toujours entouré de peau et de
courbes c'est s était d'une beauté d'une
poésie est emmerdé droit et j'ai gardé
de j'ai gardé des contacts oui
ça fait mal et où ma femme est on là les
australiennes mais là est avec son
provence à la maison il a kidnappé sa
femme qui tous se ralliaient non quand
ils se rencontrent ici dit on va jamais
pouvoir elle transforme china unicom
australie et l'autre cas paris bon
c'était compliqué et comment il a
rencontré en tours de magie des
rencontres est en cours de théâtre tu
lui fais des tours de magie est enfin je
vais jamais fait juger c'est la honte un
tour de magie pour draguer c'est la
honte ouais ça lui fait une fleur à
faire un tour de magie sont montrés que
c'est un tour de magie c'est ben ouais
j'en suis change l'eau en coca
changement en alcool pour finir la
soirée c'est pas mal et ici à jouer ici
ici j'ai joué quelques fois sur des
événements moi j'ai vu sur les dinos ici
moi j'ai vu je me souviens d'une soirée
un peu extraordinaire assis à côté de ce
héros c'était un chien michel serrault
ici qui était venu voir sur les dinos et
j'étais fan absolu et le sérum arrêt
mais mais vraiment je le vénéraient je
me souviens du laü beaucoup de
gentillesse beaucoup de sympathie et
alors qu'apparemment il n'était pas avec
tout le monde j'avais n'a pas joué ici
non j'ai pas joué c'est la première fois
que je veux quand même j'ai vu dans le
quartier j'ai vu juste la comédie de
paris ah bah ouais c'était si c'est un
succès body sinon c'est très bon c'est
le dernier cabaret qui est comme ça qui
est dans son jus il faut en profiter
avant que ça devienne un parking quoi
tu es cache très content de faire cette
commune et moi aussi
le prochain numéro c'était inévitable
dans une bonne soirée de cabaret c'est
un numéro de drag queen voilà et en même
temps une soirée dans un cabaret avec
thierry ardisson à pigalle avouez que ça
aurait été décevant qu'il n'y ait pas
des drag queens voilà
pour ceux qui connaissent pas les drag
queen c'est des hommes déguisés en
femmes voilà un petit peu comme dustin
hoffman dans tootsie ou christine boutin
dans la manif pour tous
[Applaudissements]
c'était très bien fait
ce qu'on va accueillir maintenant c'est
la troupe te précis la folle du désert
pour vous resituer s'est tirée d'un film
je vous redonne l'histoire ses trois
amis qui vont traverser l'australie dans
un bus en gros c'est un peu very bad
trip avec une plume dans le cul elles
sont belles elles sont drôles elle
chante bien et elles seront à partir du
9 février au casino de paris je vous
demande de le faire un tonnerre
d'applaudissements au dail messieurs
pour la troupe de priscilla annuel
[Musique]
oui
obama
l'habitude
oh
m
ça
et ça
allez
m
et
j'étais à la fois
4 ces cas et que nous n'avons me voir
d'aspect gaufré nina people
l'homme à la drôme
s
[Musique]
m
ouais
et
il
hélas
[Musique]
là bas
jamais
il
est
plus
m
allez
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est de la porte ça te donne envie
de voir le spectacle
ça donne envie de d'avoir des plumes à
la maison
super
dis moi ça doit changer de maintenant
bah c'est pas pareil c'est pas la même
ambiance ouatée t à nantes j'étais à
nantua et d'amener un truc sur facebook
et que c'est comme ça que marc perry je
suis à paris à l'époque ce qui t'a rendu
célèbres comme ton invitation de sarko
non coutume je suis un tricheur je vais
vous le dire pigalle c'est de l'amour
des plus et l'alcool bref j'aime les 3
et 10 mois quand on vient d'une école
catholique quand on a été élevé dans une
école catholique qu'est ce que ça fait
tomber api d'al bass et c'est vrai que
c'était pas les mêmes mais ce quoi sachs
était plutôt stricte et j'ai grandi dans
un univers assez assez cadré assez là ça
prenait la baise apprenait le catéchèse
et là je pense qu'il ya des preuves qui
auraient fait deux trois a baissé quand
même quand il mettait des femmes ton
père et mettez des klaxons non une fois
il ya mais mes amis au collège ils m'ont
offert un sac rouge et le string qui
allait avec et moi j'ai cru bon quand je
rentrais à la maison de faire une blague
à mon père
s'est mis le string pleurs oui il
n'avait pas l'habitude de voir un string
dans le salon qui bouge et quand je suis
passé dans le salon effectivement
bon je suis retournée dans la chambre
mais avec un string et une claque mais
comment comment tu peux être aussi
décomplexée alors tu viens quand même
d'une éducation plutôt strictes ben je
sais pas en fait je pense que c'est le
seul envie de s'amuser et comme je suis
très sûr de moi même dans le sens où je
sais qui je suis où je vais j'ai pas
peur nous voilà de me déguiser en femme
de machin voilà de limiter les gens je
les fais donc je m'amuse je le ferai
mais je me souviens une fois dans sa vie
éternelle tu as fait ta merde exactement
qu'est ce que ça a été repris sa main de
même tu sais que encore aujourd'hui les
gens pensent que c'est vraiment ma mère
qui est venue vraiment on dit mais ta
mère a été vite et bien sûr plateau il
ya un truc de fou que tu as fait c'est
que quand tu étais jeune talent et dans
les parfumeries tour pour renifler les
passeports et quand tu rencontres et une
gonzesse tu le disais exactement en fait
ça c'est une technique devant parce que
bon le physique qui s'améliore avec le
temps mais c'est vrai que moi je suis
parti d'une base à 6 bat la grèce et
j'ai inventé des techniques comme ça
pour draguer les filles et c'est vrai
que j'étais allé dans les parfumeries et
je mémorise l odeur et le nom de chaque
période ce dernier j'ai testé quand je
suis arrivé à paris près quand je suis
arrivé à paris la première fille à qui
je vous laisse deviner le parfum en fait
c'est sérieux là tu es là tu gagnes tu
ne sembles tu prends pour un chien quoi
a
fait quoi les gars manquaient web
assieds toi bats il va chez toi
en train de discuter de norris qui
faisaient quand il était jeune l'année
dans les parfumeries les renifler les
parfums il nous apprenait par coeur à
april aller voir des gonzesses disait
toi c'est grave de notre grade de celui
le dreg de vraiment très technique je
quitte mon grand père c'était un
ingénieur schmitt cette année il crée
des parfums et chez nous on avait normes
de parfum je vois deux fragrances la
plus douce à la plus musqué et je suis
capable de reconnaître tout le monde
connaît mon avis religieux j'ai les yeux
bandés je vais rentrer je sais que c'est
toi je sais c'est même maintenant
maintenant j'ai votre doigt dans le nez
je suis je peux vous reconnaître les
yeux bandés je vous reconnais pas bon de
refaire toutes tailles à m d'ailleurs m
arrive tu fais l'olympia lors sur le la
bienvenue
génial moi je suis très content toute la
famille qui va venir ouais voilà il ya
un gros soutien de partout et vous si
vous avez un
coeur le 24 à 16 heures le 20 à 16
heures le vent calme et façon la femme
elle bosse donc je sais que je vais bien
alors est sûre si vite on est en train
de préparer une belle petite pépite en
tout cas j'en suis très très content
très fier parce que c'est avec mon frère
et et thomas paul hévin en dessous de
gens c'est les personnes avec qui on a
créé cette série et je suis très heureux
parce qu'on a mis tout ce qu'on avait
envie de faire dedans gare à des
sketches et en une partie
feuilletonnante c'est une vraie sitcom
très content de proposer ça sur ses buts
s'est longtemps 13h01 bien je suis là
tegan est ce que tu es heureux en amour
je suis heureux partout en amour en
voiture en médecins
magnifique on est content pour toi c'est
une tension savoir comment c'est là
c'est quoi ça
public de la nouvelle à vous qui nous
regardent et sur ses 8 j'espère que vous
passez une bonne soupe
ça fait plaisir le prochain artiste
c'est un monument du music-hall français
c'est un humoriste qui a traversé les
générations il a 81 ans mesdames et
messieurs et il est toujours aussi drôle
voilà la légende dit qu'il a connu
michel drucker jeunes
geneviève de fontenay sans chapeau et
brigitte macron sans ride alors
il vient exclusivement pour nous parce
qu'il est en spectacle dans toute la
france et tous les week-ends au théâtre
de l'archipel pour son spectacle même
pas mort il vient nous faire un sketch
collector qui raconte l'histoire d'un
vieux qui va au bois de boulogne
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande de
faire un tonnerre d'applaudissements
pour monsieur popeck
oh
je pense que vous n'êtes pas de
parisiens parce que j'ai l'habitude d'un
comme ça en provence mais pas paris
c'est la première fois même
pire et vous que l'autre soir j'ai
sortait d'un restaurant de la porte
maillot tu
ou que j'étais allé dîner pour fêter
l'anniversaire de mon mariage avec ma
femme
j'avais décidé d pas regardé à la
dépense
surtout que je dise tél
c'est à dire que on s'était disputé les
matins n'avait pas voulu venir et j'ai
messi d'ici germé deçà des mains se la
pète et réconcilier savoir écouter les
doubles
surtout qu'on s'était pas disputer pour
grand chose
me dit oui depuis qu'on est marié qui
m'a jamais rien a ajouté j'ai dit ma
chérie tu m'as jamais dit que tu avais
quelque chose à vendre
elle est
elle est très susceptible
je ne sais pas comment on a fait vous
savez la première fois que je les verts
sortent et des déchets la playlist un
gros bouquet de roses entre les bras ça
a été le coup de foudre je vous le dis
franchement
si vous saviez comme j'aimerais être à
la place de ces roses rien que pour être
serré dans mes bras elle me répond sans
se retourner ne vous y fiez pas dès
qu'elle arrive chez moi j'ai la coupe la
queue
rey doit être masochiste parce que je
vous raconte pas la première nuit quand
la patience en boum dierick sadate mais
ça vaut le détour on était allongé dans
un champ des marguerites
non c'était par des marguerites c'était
des vétérans
on était là sous la clair de la lune et
je me dis bien qu'il ya un moment voire
été dit regardez le savez pas par où
commencer gdgt pissos pour vous dire
franchement que j'avais à peine trente
deux ans bref
je la prends mon courage dans les deux
mains et débitant blanc je me pose la
question je lui dit cherry voulez-vous
être ma femme dès ce soir elle me répond
vous me prenez pour une [__] je dis
mais pratique tout qui sait que vous en
parler d'argent
[Applaudissements]
oui
après les dîners j'ai roulé
tranquillement abordé ma vieille
mercedes des collections
vous êtes déjà nés au bois de boulogne à
deux heures du matin c'est le seul
endroit que je connaisse ou que quand
vous donnez un coup d'épée dans un
ruisseau il vous le rang
donc je roulais tranquillement dans ma
vieille mercedes et collection contes
arrive derrière moi une voiture qui
commence à me faire des appels de phare
ici les presser si de l'aide à tapas et
non six en tout cas d'un débat moi qui
roulait encore plus doucement alors moi
aussi j'ai fait des appels de phare pour
qu'il aille plus vite au lieu de ça ils
s'arrêtent obligeant démarrer tiens moi
aussi il descend de voiture moi j'avais
aussi de sortir ma mondialisation
je tremblais pas donc je tremble pas
mais comme il faut toujours là j'étais
avant de s'en servir jacqueline
j'agitais j'habitais il faut être il
faut pas la victime et dit bonjour
messieurs
ouvre
à celui qu'il est derrière et descend de
voiture il dit bonjour tout le monde où
on va
moi je vais chez moi
six gp déposer quelqu'un
à ce moment là je vois pas cnsd il dit
les berlines le jabot de dentelle la
jaquette que ça bloque yoplait mais
contre tout le monde fut la cas de la
grange
où je dis j'ai compris
geci tomber dans une noce et mais
prennent pour quelqu'un de la famille
moi que j'ai toujours rêvé d'y mettre
des connaissances aristocratique pour
l'échangé de ma vie médiocratique j'ai
sauté sur l'occasion du g suivi écouté
on dirait trouvait dans un château
oublié dans une partie il y avait une
servante elle en avait une jeep o'grady
qui pour nous accueillir elle avait une
décolleté très creuse sans forme de
bénitier pour faire la quête d'ailleurs
chacun lui remettait un billet est la
mauricie je n'ai rien et jérémy ma carte
je bois un monsieur qui commence à se
déshabiller
mais alors complètement
je me dis tiens sol et des propriétaires
il va déjà se coucher
mais petit à petit tout le monde s'est
déshabillée à bâle ne savait plus où
mettre les mains alors moi aussi pour la
boîte contenant j'ai enlevé mes
chaussures je vois un espèce de type
tony qui arrivent vers moi et qui
commence à me regarder dans l'air comme
s'ils venaient désirez vous savez
moi aussi j'ai le regard des données
comme si je ne désirez pas
mais dit il va gagner tous impôts et et
sauce est mon coco tu aurais dis donc on
n'a pas gardé les cochons ensemble
je voulais me sauver
je voulais me sauver je vais trouver
pris mes shows si on me les a mais pour
les mechaussie alors traversé une pièce
à moitié que les rides excusez moi de
vous déranger mais personne n'aurait
misé au tir et alors doit pardonner mon
expression qui est des qui a l'air au
moins deux douzaines de kim et des kits
uni où je me suis dit c'est le moment ou
jamais j'ai sorti ma carte car son nom y
tenez j'ai toutes les tailles
mesdames et messieurs à tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour monsieur papin
qui bourré
[Applaudissements]
quelle classe
vous dites ou ans raconte les coulisses
on lui a fait un petit plaisir on l'a
mis dans la même loge que les danseuses
et si vous voulez qu'il en fasse
mesdames et messieurs ne bougeait pas
chez vous on revient dans quelques
instants avec plein de surprises c'est
le moment de faire une petite pause on y
travaille apparemment rien eric antoine
mustapha el atrassi vous pouvez vous
découvrir les jambes on revient dans
quelques instants sur cible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le prochain numéro madame des messieurs
je suis ravi parce que c'est un numéro
pour moi c'est plus en télévision c'est
ce qu'on appelle du transformisme voilà
là et c'est de l'inédit rien que pour
vous ce soir la nouvelle eve et cheyrou
sur ces 8 c'est stromae voilà stromae
tout le monde connaît savez c'est le
talent de jacques brel avec des fringues
choper chez mondial moquette
c'est mi chou qui nous l'a prêté et et
je dois être honnête jamais j'aurais
imaginé dire cette phrase un jour dans
ma vie ainsi après vous inquiétez pas on
a fait l'état des lieux avant et on va
le rendre dans le même état après
mesdames et messieurs pour vous le
public de la nouvelle eve je vous
demande accueillir très chaleureusement
monsieur straumann
au windsor
soit
tu étais formidable j'étais formidable
il nous étions formidable
[Musique]
armissan
dites moi d'où il vient enfin je saurai
où je vais
dit que lorsqu'on cherche bien on finit
toujours par trouver elle dit qu'il
n'est jamais très loin qu'il part très
souvent travaillé maman dit travailler
c'est bien bien mieux qu'être mal
accompagné barret souhaitons pas
ton papa
ça n'est pas pas
su cacher ça doit faire moi mille fois
que j'ai compté mes doigts
m
[Musique]
d
pourrait-on pas
dis moi ton papa sans même devoir lui
parler il sait ce qu'ils ne par un sacré
papables dis moi tu caches et ça doit
faire au moins mille fois que j'ai
compté mes doigts
équipement
quoi
s'y cacher
g
des mets toi
des femmes
[Musique]
et
alors
ah ah
[Musique]
m
à
laon
[Musique]
allez faut
[Applaudissements]
rarement
incroyable
je connais que l'art morgan duthes ou
bonjour madame c'est la première non
mais sérieux c'est la première fois que
vous voyez frais afin qu'on se voit fait
moi je t'ai vu de 33 ouais bah oui j'ai
vu ses films 1 oui non papa maman non
oui bien sûr mais sa préférence voix
ambrée ouais je trouve que tu es devenu
plutôt beau gosse là tu crois tu as dû
souffrir à l'adolescence sans essien et
je crois que j'ai la barbe ce blog la
barbe ça cache tout ouais elle est
triplement de tous les trucs à main
armée tu as l'air de mecs un peu
mystérieux franchement comment tu veux
je trouve franchement ce cas rien me
dire
ça va lorsque drôle c'est qu'il a
commencé dans un gars une fille je
faisais les mains il était de dos et
comme apte que mon arme comme et poils
de dos mes épaules et tooway étaient
très polis dans les journaux mais
c'était à lui l'armée arménienne là là
tu te rases là non la whey jusque là ça
fait le code mais là je suis torse nu
mais tu as fait un gars une fille ouais
je suis arrivé à paris au bout de deux
jours j'étais dans un gars une fille et
sera permis de payer - oui sauf que tu
passes et jamais je devais toujours de
doter et toujours la buav acta et puis
un jour ils passent enfin dans la gamme
fit au bout de trois ans on gagne firent
la productrice me dire on va enfin voir
ta tête sinon tu vas faire une un truc
avec jean dujardin face à face j'avertis
tous les arméniens de france et ça
commence à passer on me voit arriver et
la flash info spécial pujadas qui
annonce que saddam hussein est tombé
l'épisode n'est jamais passé sa grand
mère lui dit tu étais pas mal mais
l'épisode était un peu bizarre il reste
déficiente un truc qui tombe il
m'appelle très bien et lyon ça doit
faire un choc quand d'arrivée de de
perpignan du milieu arménien et tout
débarqué à paris apicale quand j'ai joué
les premiers sketchs au moloko way en
phase donc ça en face des étoiles
s'étaient pas la tour eiffel que tu
voulais voir c'était ça il y avait deux
trois endroits à l'époque à paris où tu
pouvais jouer et le moloco faisait
partie ces endroits là ont joué très
tard il y avait je me rappelle on
faisait une pièce de théâtre on était
quatre ou cinq sur scène je crois et le
mec du moloko et nous dire il ya deux
personnes dans la salle est-ce que tu
joues est-ce que tu joues pas et je te
jure je dis on joue on donc tout ce
qu'on a à la fin on salue et avait deux
personnes devant ils font
bouffer [__] je te jure de servir de
jouer devant des gens qui bouffe non sa
meilleure école ouais c'est comme jouer
dans des bars en fait si les gens sont
venus faire autre chose si tu arrive à
capter leur attention c'est ce que tu
raconte sur scène et bien en fait je dis
un truc que j'adore ces jeux les bouffer
du sable a baissé comme rocky qui va
taper dans la viande et même là là j'en
suis à mon deuxième spectacle tous les
soirs je vais jouer dans des bars pour
tester des nouveaux trucs et la nature
mais alors comment cela se passe ça va
ça va on a de la chance et il ya
beaucoup de monde il ya beaucoup de
dates et je fais mon métier en fait moi
même été à perpignan le 14 décembre je
joue chez moi ouais ça c'est la
comédienne arménien à perpignan
avec mes parents mais on est trois en
fait les amateurs dont il ya beaucoup
n'y a pas une grosse commune en termes
réels et sur marseille lyon valence ils
sont tous remontés sur sur paris le sens
du temps fou parce que si ça se passe
mal cherche l'amour non plus tu
redeviendras juristes qu'est ce que tu
es crime où j'étais criminologue riblon
j'étais passionné par les tueurs en
série donc est ici tu ya eu pas loin de
taki genres qui georges cas et équipages
étrangers enlisé dans un bistrot avec
baffie c'était bourré la gueule avec une
histoire leur vie mais se bourrer la
gueule belle-fille et découvre à la télé
son pote c'est le tueur en série guy
georges un mec avec qui il avait une
relation a mis 25 ans qui discutait le
tube attaquant c'était à dijon c'était
extraordinaire enfin cette histoire
oh
sur scène clara morgane encore mustapha
el atrassi mais le numéro suivant c'est
un ventriloque extrêmement talentueuse
ventriloque qui est qui on peut le dire
c'est pas un métier extrêmement féminin
voilà c'est vrai ya plus d'hommes que de
femmes et en même temps si les femmes
étaient capables de parler tout en
gardant la bouche fermée c'est vrai que
ça serait
non c'est très misogyne ce que j'ai dit
ah parce que les hommes aussi sont
capables de dire des conneries tout en
gardant la bouche fermée regarder donald
trump sur twitter donc vraiment
alors d'habitude quand on pense
ventriloque on pense tout de suite à un
homme avec une grosse moustache qui fait
parler une peluche lui il a décidé
d'aller beaucoup plus loin mesdames et
messieurs il est venu avec une invitée
spéciale qui va vous faire chavirer je
peux vous le garantir mesdames et
messieurs un tonnerre d'applaudissements
pour monsieur marc métral
bonsoir à tous merci
merci du fond du coeur effectivement
dans ma région qui plus est invitée très
spéciale juste pour vous miss où elle
dit comment l'ol dit
mchugh a pas répondu aux à quai qui
parle ici mccarthy no
c'est pas vrai elle parle c'est génial
ça allait aller dit quelque chose de
votre nom
pourquoi écoute moi j'ai plein de
questions où c'est que tu appris à
parler à l'école
avec le oui mais des chiens et vont pas
à l'école école privée à iveta plus
cette école non et pourquoi je voulais
apprendre l'anglais et y avait pas de
professeur berger allemand
ah oui mais dans ces cas là tu sais ce
qu'ils on se connaît tous pourquoi tu tu
m'a pas appelé au téléphone au plus
téléphone un problème de batterie non
des puces
de puces de puces toinon regardé le
magnifique 1 on dirait une peluche ça va
plaire à sarkozy
commencé à travailler plus pour gagner
plus
alors oui c'est vrai que les chiens les
présidences une longue histoire vous
avez vu que le président macro
maintenant ils adopter les mots un joli
labrador noir il te laisse pas
indifférent j'ai pas raciste
elle est très séductrice on a joué pour
la reine d'angleterre un buckingham
palace elle est tombée amoureuse à des
gorki un obligé pourquoi donc ces points
et attend voir comment tu entendu ou
avec nemo le chien de macron allez on
est entre nous la tendance c'est un
marche
c'est en marche oui le président
hollande puis l'avesnois il avait pas de
chien ainsi un rottweiller
rottweiller n'ont pu d'ailleurs elle et
il n'a pas gardé longtemps un y avait
plus de niches fiscales
oui ça sert en effet ça arrive
alors maintenant maintenant pour
l'émission elle a préparé quelque chose
de spécial allez allez vas-y non alors à
temps et maintenant que si bon ok alors
on y va niant
olala ya un petit bug laddh un petite
erreur dans ces écoutes moi c'est waouh
on va reprendre tu n'es pas un chat tué
un chien polyglotte
dis donc qui c'est qui fait le texte
c'est waouh c'est moi tu me prends
imprenable cl oui
c'est ma soirée
tous les deux filets fait
non seulement mashing more more vente je
connais les paroles doyer une touffe au
caire est allé et on est marin
qu'est-ce qu'il est lourd
marie-philippe basique la ville test
mais non tu l'as d'or va te faire
ensemble à 6
puis
rien
[Musique]
il
triste intérêts
non
allez on se fâche
mais ça
bon
c'est simple si ses coéquipiers
le prochain artiste c'est monsieur jean
phi janssen passait bien je n'aime coup
j'en fis je les aime beaucoup il avait
certainement écouté sur les grosses
têtes chez laurent ruquier à rtl il
aurait pu bosser chez michou aussi jean
phi voilà problème c'est qu'il aurait
fait stallone pour être tout à fait
honnête non je vais être très honnête
aussi vous raconter un petit peu les
collisions fiche de connaître très bien
parce qu'on a vécu ensemble
le temps d'un week-end
ils remplissaient la petite et moi je
pourrais la grande et non c'était dans
un café théâtre voilà bref on a défoncé
tout le monde et ça fait un an et demi
que je n'ai pas vu je suis très ému je
suis très heureux de le recevoir ici à
la nouvelle eve mesdames et messieurs je
vous demande de faire un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour monsieur jean
philippe dorcet
beau temps les gens
et ben moi je me présente je m'appelle
jean phi et j'ai un petit village du
nord la ola au l'a poussé à la frontière
belge l'ocs ont fait des courses du
tracteur là on fait des concours à la
guerre l'amour entre les enfants dans le
jardin
alors moi mais tout ça c'est fait j'ai
vite compris que j'étais différent
très sensible
trop ni [__] quoi et si je voulais
m'en sortir fallait vite que je me sens
pas finira pas le coût d'une fourche non
parce que vous à paris vous réalisez pas
parce qu'à paris cet art danse à paris
c'est la mode le monde gay la vie gay
mon copain gay 1 mais dans le nord à
250km d'années lumière d'ici à des gens
n'appellent pas c'est un gun appelle ça
une marit hoult voisins
c'est pas pareil niveau la perception à
mon copain marie tout haut le mariage
marie tooth tools lamari tout le parage
c'est pas pareil
le plus dur je crois en fait pour
l'annoncer basse et les parents alors
moins apparente à ma mère ma taille 130
kg qui part du principe que comme elle
est grosse ça ne sert à rien qu'elle met
une petite ballerine petites boucles
d'oreilles alors elle claque du caillou
un site mais d'où la tarte comme ça en
gros c'est comme si cafres et du tuning
mais pas sans la voiture assurez la
et puis tout est en proportion il va pas
avoir un caniche un ballon ça fait qu'on
la saint bernard il s'appelle obélix et
130 kg comme elle et ma mère tu prends
de ses robes tu mets sur la table ça
fait une nappe et pétain mon père
lambert wii u c'est le gros rustre du
nord lui parle pas beaucoup de quoi tu
parles on comprend pas ce qu'il dit
alors eu de la chance de parents
figurent toi parce qu'ils ont quatre
beaux enfants un plat l'échantillon
combien esseulé catinot et 2 2 deux
homosexuels ça fait un gros rassure
quand même également ta vie de marie
tooth taule
il ya moins pied ma soeur en fait il ya
une inversion ce tu veux elle c'est moi
et moi c'est elle
pour info aujourd'hui elle est chauffeur
routier moche hôtesse de l'air a
[Applaudissements]
c'est un cercle qui l'a dit en premier
un jour elle l'avait fait au moment où
parce que c'est une lesbienne ma soeur
mais c'est pas jodie foster n'ont rien à
voir enfin maman au chou green
qu'est ce qui t'a dit quoi
je lesbiennes une copine
des rien à ton père dit rien at on peur
ils vont pas supporter dit rien dit rien
je fais de tampon à bon temps pour quand
même à
sauf que ben sera libéré avec c'est
d'être en harmonie avec elle même alors
elle a fini par le dire oh bah la
réaction des parents je sais que ma mère
qui était déjà forte est belle nous a
forci par déchets et puis mon père avec
la contrariété l'a commencé à perdre ses
cheveux toi mais avec le temps ça s'est
estompé mais ces écoutes moi bien ma
soeur elle avait même le droit de venir
à la maison avec sa petite copine et ses
petites copines époque elle s'appelait
clara enfin non mais ça peut être un
père à laver des tests croisés le
portefeuille que la chaîne des grosses
godasses et elle conduisait début semble
approprié mais mon père il aimait bien
je te jure il avait accepté il l'adoré
même parce qu'elle ait changé ses
plaquettes de freins
est elle tombée le gazon
[Applaudissements]
mais quelques années plus tard c'est à
mon tour de dire et moi j'avais une
petite appréhension c'est un peu plus
dur pour un garçon est en fait c'est ma
mère qui l'a senti ça devienne maman le
sang ces choses là un jour elle est
rentrée dans la chambre elle va poser
directement la question enfin
directement à nous pour dire le mot elle
arrive elle a fait bon gamin
elle avoue que c'est oui dans le nord on
ne fait pas les subjectif
manav que je sais estime comme ça
comme quoi c'est bien là comme celle là
comme sa maman mais comme ça là là là
une marie de toul à homo oui ça
recommence
geely a tout fait
rien rien fait tampon
[Applaudissements]
merci
car si les gens
jean fille elle belle surprise
employables alors mon jeune fille c'est
bien ça n'aurait plus de faire du
cabaret comme ça je crois que j'aurais
adoré ou un côté paillettes plumes
surtout les plumes mais que tu l'aimés
travaux qu'elle gagnait cette belle ta
part toute étiquette pas j'aime bien
quand tu parles de marée tout sous la
marque surtout la bastille une mégère
chez c'est quelqu'un que je dis du 20/02
des gens mais par des formations ma mère
a considéré que ça voulait dire une
petite tempête j'ai su que tu connais sa
ville avait une boutique de fringues
[Musique]
fringues sauf que ton mac à l'époque
c'est un escroc oui c'est ça il s'est
cassé avec la caisse et moi j'avais une
maison il vit là une piscine les suisses
ils sont tous venus chercher huawei et
j'ai dû payer essayé mais c'est bien
tout ce qu'a fait que je suis devenu
stewart a pris et de stewards c'est ce
que je suis devenu artiste insiste gold
dans les avions la nuit ça pèse oui oui
on va pas se mentir oui il se passe des
choses oui ça s'appelle faire partie du
club des dix mille faire l'amour à dix
mille pieds parce qu on part du principe
que les relations sont décuplées
qu'altitude et toi tu as besoin en
altitude non potable en altitude oui je
défie oui ça m'est arrivé oui deuxième
c'est bon ah oui mais je voulais faire
passer de 18 jours moi essayer une fois
je défie je tapais des gonzesses sauvé
par new way oui pour moi bah non je
crois que je sais depuis très longtemps
que je suis différent je crois que j'ai
des images de moi ces temps en train de
regarder catalogue de la redoute à la
page des slips et que ça me faisait
quelque chose dont j'étais populaire
mais après j'essaye de personnel donc tu
fais tu t'es tu essayes bon c'est pas
pour ça mais c'était bien c'est bien
elle était contente à la dame adams
était sa maman
son spectacle ça marche oui je suis
content c'est une belle histoire janvier
d'école
ccc rigoles ou quoi ce kit est arrivé
quand alain juppé et adam
toi aussi tu vois un obstacle un nom il
a une notoriété ou à l'alhambra à la
nombreux à partir du 1er décembre et et
pour quelques temps donc on attend bref
un beau des grains des piles à l'ombre
en quoi la scène musicale à la salle
mythique à paris et je peux pas
embrasser vas-y tu es de
hockey lah c'est vrai qu'il a guéri
rejeté quand vous adopterez un gosse à
la wii en 20 ans je n'ai obtenu
messieurs marquée des cours pendant ce
laps de temps vous serez tenté de
changer de programme cependant à chaque
fois que vous changez de chaîne il y
aura un chaton des pc dans le monde je
vous laisse avec votre conscience à tout
de suite c'est oui
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes toujours à nouvelle année
nous passons à samedi soir à pigalle
qui dit mieux évidemment di dance kids
id ans à pigalle c'est le french cancan
seulement d'applaudir très très fort
toute la troupe de la nouvelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore les canards j'adore le club
anglais arsenal reste mais toi tu as un
truc qui s'appelle le cabaret de caraman
rien oui d'itinérants et j'ai plein
d'artistes que j'adore tout autant de
mois de ville se refuse donc cabaret et
pas des petits andy effeuillage
burlesque fait un peu plus chic tu
verras tout à l'heure alors comment ça
va c'est un peu son calendrier cette
année exact patel rouge à gaza ouais
c'est tout sur l'eau
l'année dernière est quand même un
scandale quand tommy hilfiger dans la
bouche de testeur ça va quand même plus
de l'histoire ainsi esquissé avec un
cigare non parce qu'on ne sait quoi
l'esprit malawi très mal classée c'est
quoi ce combat de cette année
j'ai passé l'âge y'en a pas chaque année
non anesthésistes
rouge comment ça va être jérémy alors
c'est les photographes ton calendrier ah
ouais exact c'est super dur de travail
toi quand même parce que le mec qui se
doit de dire est ce que j'ai sur ma cité
dur c'était bien trop agi c'est dur si
vous
avez un enfant
oui une petite
c2 là l'autre là vient avec moi toi au
nom bien ici regarde le nom le sonore on
ne soulève pas les jupes des filles ont
fait ça est-ce que ça fait pas dans les
magnifiques la lehman pitavy léger quel
âge on est voisins par amour on habite
dans le même village de parent non
non non non elle est indiqué chez les
mains on n'est pas formé par les avenues
mais rotois tout à l'air chaud c'est ben
non je vais pas m'excuser je vous savez
le noir ici tu fais un truc un peu plus
tu veux bien passer à côté de séries
fabien la super alors tiens tu te
souviens les bouteilles que j'ai faire
part à tout à l'heure les bouteilles
[__] je le montrais un peu comment ça
marche les apparitions de champagne
souvent ça ça marche alors c'est le
foulard un gars c'est ce soir c'est un
petit peu un moment après gala si tu
vois ce dossier
là la puce de monnaie je veux la mettre
dans l'oeuf là je vais tenter de la
faire disparaître c'est vraiment le truc
le plus classique est ce que serge est
un beau gros plan de cinq ans mais la
pièce ici tu vois super et là tu fais ça
comme ça
cela passe c'est là bas mais c'est pas
mal et regardez là parfois on pense
qu'elle est elle est juste la voix un
coup ou parfois on pense qu'elle est
juste là sous votre coupe tu vois ou
alors elle est sous la bouteille de
la bouteille de champ alors là tu vois
on est à la troisième bouteille de champ
et on va faire un truc super avec ça ne
quittez jamais ces bouteilles des yeux
parce que ça va scheer et ça ça va être
énorme j'ai prévu ici cher copain les
tiens on va faire la carrière conjuguées
de clara morgane et de laurent baffie
dans ce petit carnet j'ai noté des
oeuvres de laurent et de clara alors il
faut deviner est-ce que c'est laurent
clara qui a fait face à jacques chirac
alors laurent très bien bronzer un bourg
de la a pourtant on serait peut être les
deux
les anges de la télé réalité car ok on
est bon projet x klein ouais toujours
bon donc il y en a plein burger quiz et
open bar est d'ailleurs aimé le film
nist mythique et mystique mintya sexe
magouille et culture générale sa
première pièce de théâtre parfait donc
là ce qu'on va faire chasser laurent qui
va choisir qui va commencer comme ça tu
mets le carnet comme ça dans ta main et
l'autre 20e et de su comme ça et le
right on pousse la suivre sur une page
sur une phase où la montre pas tu ouvres
l'apache contre et on va là montré à la
caméra ici je ne sais pas ce que c'est
oui mais bon c'est juste que ça tu t'en
souviendras
ici les amis je mets ce carnet sous
cette bouteille d'accord ok vous souriez
n'était ce sera deux chiffres cette
année j'ai fait un miracle de dingue
cette année les amis c'était l'amour
pendant une heure cinq de suite sans
m'arrêter a sauté au moment du passage à
l'heure d'été
la conteuse avec ma chérie et là on à la
carrière de thierry donc la deuxième
jour de coupe
on a du mal vivre en jeu
lundi matin paris der
sar et en plus on arrive 1,93 thierry à
toi mon pote tu choisis tu ouvres le
carnet d'un courage leur accord on y va
pour nous d'avoir mon papa c'est bon non
c'est ma meilleure émission c'est vrai
ok super donc cela on a mais la belle
clara
on va le faire son carnet je vais tenter
de pénétrer ton esprit dans un premier
temps
je vais lire tes pensées se demander de
penser un des invités prestigieux de
syrie alors thiery a reçu plein plein de
monde il a reçu ray charles matte m
brad pitt brad pitt oui absolument et
puis des moins bien aussi qu'on aimerait
roumanie
thierry meyssan rim et son chéri mais
sans doute heures américain vivait
donc voilà par exemple ces gens là tu
peux penser à une de ces personnes là
par exemple tu as quelqu'un en tête
ménard je me regarde dans les yeux tu
penses à cette personne alors c'est très
flatteur mais face à cette personne si
ça y est gelé
et ça cette bouteille c'est la tienne ce
qui est très étonnant c'est que je pense
que tout à l'heure
ici il y avait un carnet et là j'ai une
étiquette et si j'enlève le tic est
qu'ils avaient choisi la pièce tough si
t'as pas que tu as choisie hu a pas mal
et la syrie toi tu avais choisi quoi
dans tes émissions tu avais choisi simon
webbe choisi hardy matt et toi que la
date a même pas eu de carnets mais t'as
pensé à une personne une et une seule
clé la personne à qui tu as pensé bref
si brad pitt aurait pu choisir des
dizaines de on est d'accord et je me dis
mille du rapid on n'est pas complice le
jure tu mens tu vas en enfer si tu crois
pas l'enfer tu des ménages en syrie on
est d'accord m non mais bon regardez
bien ici sous cette étiquette il ya un
seul
nom mélanie
c'est mon métier est génial quand même
butt ça fait plaisir c'est que pour toi
je dois gagner un maximum de venir me
débrouille mais moi
le numéro qui va suivre c'est ennuyeux
on ne voit pas souvent alors certains
aiment dresser des chiens des lions lui
scélérat
tout de suite j'ai l'impression d'avoir
mis une très mauvaise ambiance il ya
peut-être deux infos mais il ya
certainement une mauvaise pour certains
mais il y en a surtout une bonne c'est
que oui c'est des rats mais ils sont
dressés et entre nous entre des rats
dressé et des éléphants pas dresser je
préfère qu'ils s'occupent des rats je
vous demande de l'accueillir extrêmement
chaleureusement fait un maximum de bruit
madame monsieur pour monsieur gunther
sac fans
[Applaudissements]
à la meinau à messieurs
auch est approché ne ratez pas notre
prochain numéro nous allons maintenant
si vous voulez bien faire un petit
numéro de magie tous ensemble et je vais
tout vous expliquer soyez très attentifs
puisque comme ça vous allez pouvoir
refaire ce numéro dès votre retour ce
soir à la maison pour le plus grand
plaisir de la famille alors pense du
numéro de magie c'est très simple il
vous faut des rats
alors je pense que vous n'avez pas sur
vous alors vous inquiétez pas puisque
j'en ai une sacrée famille alors à
tatouille s'ils voulaient venir
ratatouille il est là bien évidemment
bah oui en chair en os et tout en quoi
l'un mais ratatouille ne voyagent jamais
tout seul bien évidemment il est
toujours accompagné de radiateur bien
évidemment son copain il y a également
raccourci aussi il y en a du monde
d'ailleurs tiens y'a raviolis qu'est
venu également aujourd'hui ils sont tous
là vous avez de la chance bien plus et
qui ont baissé rappelé un plan où ils
sont tous là vous en avez encore
baîllonner encore une ben vous avez de
la chance
c'est ragnagnas
bah oui mais rania niant vous attendez
pas important dans quinze jours c'était
prévu mais enfin vous êtes là on va
pouvoir faire le spectacle
alors vous choisissez donc avec
précision et attention votre rat on va
prendre at à tout tir venez venez avec
moi là on va se mettre justice y voit la
ratatouille venez avec moi non revenait
non ne mordez pas le doigt ratatouille
ça fait mal non arrêtez de me mordre le
doigt depuis va falloir y aller parce
qu'on a du retard en plus vers la hâte à
tous s'il vous plaît donc ratatouille on
va pas y arriver un ratage tu venais
guano ratatouille en on va te donnons un
schéma
vous inquiétez pas
il s'agit que de vieilles chaussettes
et ratatouille vous avez fait votre
petit effet on va commencer donc le
numéro de bâches et donc pour ce numéro
de magie je vous le disais tout à
l'heure il vous faut bien évidemment un
rat avant de commencer le numéro c'est
très important il va falloir donc
vérifier l'élasticité de votre animal
alors oui oh je sais je sais ça peut
paraître un petit détail mais vous allez
comprendre dans quelques secondes que ce
détail forcément son importance une fois
ceci vérifiez vous remettez donc votre
petit rat à l'intérieur d'une grande
malle comme celle ci vous prenez donc
votre rat ou bt dedans
voilà comme ceci et puis là c'est très
simple il vous faut une pompe à vélo
vous branchez donc votre pompe à vélo à
la malle comme ceci et puis là vous
gonfler tout simplement alors vous bon
fait gonfler encore un petit peu on fait
encore mais pour gonfler encore un petit
peu mais vous gonfler encore un petit
peu de pays vont donc là encore un petit
peu et vaut complet encore un petit peu
puis vous regonfler puis puis vous
arrêter dans sa dernière trop gonflé
vous débranchez votre pompe à vélo vous
la laissez juste là derrière et puis là
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs à
brens kadabra vous obtenez enfin si ça
vient marcher un
couple c'est très très bien marché vous
obtenez mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs les plus gros rat démons
au possible et marie sont deux pandas à
les iphone à me connaissez la bouteille
alors encore mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs voici pour vous le plus gros
rat du monde de cimmérie
l'énormissime ruben
alesi ruben vous connaissez la route
bravo combat vous pouvez prendre votre
place bien évidemment allez-y monsieur
ruben prenez votre temps mieux vaut
peut-être falloir penser à faire un
régime un jour vous allez plus passé
entre les barreaux enfin je dis ça je
dis rien cependant je vous en prie je
vous perturbe prenez votre temps
monsieur vous mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs un tonnerre d'applaudissements
pour les plus gros noms
c'est beaucoup c'est donc soirée tête du
gabon
[Musique]
il
eh bien non
mesdames et messieurs on peut l'appeler
incantatoire
5h05 mannequin vous retrouve partout en
france et surtout au cirque bouglione
jusqu'en 2018
vous avez eu très peur tout va bien
c'est quoi monsieur votre prénom alain
d'accord tu habites walhain
d'accord à la tap le tout d'un coup je
te parle tout va bien ta vie dans le
sud-ouest habitent tous dans le
sud-ouest agenda corps toi aussi tu as
une moustache et mais moi c'est pour
déconner je la retiens ce soit un jeu
d'accord alain tu fais quoi dans la vie
retraités d'accord et qu'est ce que tu
faisais avant de te prendre les couilles
alors du coup
qu'est ce que tu fais avant la prépare
dont
bibliothèque ton livre préféré c'est
quoi
tom pouce voilà c'est un million 22 la
soirée à la honte
[Applaudissements]
au malawi à la mecque le monde s'est
blessé au bras il faut qu'un agresseur
de chat oui et les chats bouffe les
rames et des rats comme ça il peut pas
les blâmer salue les rats que c'est
quand même c'est un hommage à anne
hidalgo en fait c'est à dire que pour
rendre hommage aux paris d'aujourd'hui
il faut montrer des rats il y en a pas
comme ça sur paris il y en a beaucoup il
y en a plus grands comme ça il ya des
gros a en même temps il ya à manger sur
des bêtes comme ça déjà bouffé durera
sans savoir moi j'ai bouffé des insectes
ya pas longtemps oui moi aussi du vélo
la bouche ouverte et un beau flop 10
mois était comédien pendant dix ans
d'âge et après ça oui mais je préfère
oublier et le public a préféré oublier
aussi tu as joué breizh quand même jouer
brest y jouer shakespeare marleau j'ai
joué moi-même puisque j'ai fait du café
théâtre dont nous écrivions nous mêmes
les pièces j'ai joué copie et j'ai joué
chaval copistes génelard et l'homosexuel
où la difficulté de ces copistes est
alors un jour tu te maries et tu feras
un carton pour remercier les gens
détenus at-on mariage d'avoir fait des
cadeaux web et tu fais un chat qui saute
une chatte c'est ça oui c'était un
carton joliment dessinée s'était envoyé
d'abord une madame chat très souriante 1
et puis on ouvre le carton et vous voyez
que monsieur était en train de
l'utiliser pour apparier adjoint tout ou
bien et c'était 3 ans avant la naissance
du personnage et trois ans plus tard
quand journal le soir bruxelles m'a
demandé des reventes est un personnage
j'ai mis ce chat debout je lui fais
porter un manteau une cravate et dire
des conneries et essai de partie et je
les ai inventées le 3 mars 83 à 10
heures et demie du soir s'en souvient
oui parce que à ce moment là je les suis
après hergé était en train de mourir
dans un hôpital parisien à l'heure
précise où j'ai vingtaine chiens et de
daims et 21e challenge alors ce chat est
un homme déguisé en chat c'est un humain
au fond et il balance sur tous les
sujets et candy qui balance ses qui
traitent des sujets avec violence des
sujets durs des sujets il ya par exemple
un dessin dans lequel il n'apparaît pas
dans le livre où on voit deux types avec
plein de trous autour d'eux et des mini
cercueil et le titre c'est faut-il
enterrer en kamikaze comme il a choisi
de mourir à et est resté dans mon goût
il ya un dessin dans lequel le ch a dit
je plains le type qui se réveille avec
la tête dans qu surtout s'il est un cerf
ou un caribou oui voilà les choses
comment il aborde des sujets légers des
sujets graves il répond à des questions
que personne ne se pose ils balancent
des conneries sur tous les sujets et
visiblement ce qu'ils ont lu trouve que
c'est le meilleur que c'est l'union et
que c'est le plus violent sevel comment
il s'appelle chacun son chat chacun son
chat chacun son chat c'est pas un truc
pour les gendarmes et isabelle mergault
par exemple parler de saïdia quand ça va
être ta femme nous allons fêter nos 41
ans de vie commune c'est admirable je
vis un truc que j'adore c'est je veux
pas qu'elle fasse de chirurgie
esthétique et je rêve de serrer dans mes
bras une petite vieille witch est très
rare ça parce qu'en général des mecs au
bout d'un moment ils divorcent quand
même oui ou alors il sert dans leurs
bras une vieille qui est refaite et
s'est pas séparé toujours jouais pas
mieux non je rêve parce que ça veut dire
c'est lui envoyer un mais deux messages
c'est lui dire j'ai envie que nous
fassions tout notre vie ensemble ça veut
dire que je continue à la trouvais belle
comme un soleil et ça veut dire que
j'espère rester amoureux d'elle jusqu'à
jusqu'à la fin je crois enfin je la sens
bien mentalement ça marche tu mal mais
absolument trouver là en fait quand je
tu me parle d'elle j'ai le coeur qui bat
plus froids mais c'est génial
mais alors je parle ma part ça me
revient pas mais en même temps que le
malaxe la piste
mesdames et messieurs c'est moment
marqué une courte pause j'ai aucune
promesse à vous faire à part que si vous
avez aimé le début je vous garantis que
vous allez adorer la suite à tout de
suite sur ces 8
[Applaudissements]
on passa semble un samedi soir à pigalle
depuis la nouvelle eve la prochaine
artiste ça fait 15 ans qu'on la connaît
elle a eu mille et une vies et
aujourd'hui elle a monté un cabaret
itinérant donc forcément elle était
obligatoirement invité ici ce soir je
vous demande de faire un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour mademoiselle
clara morgane
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
demain would make up
pour
le tessin
l'instinct
chanson
chez
oui encore
je sais
oui
[Musique]
g
tiens
je
saleh
[Musique]
et vous
rés
ok
[Musique]
mais oh
il se tait
[Musique]
on trouvait le
ouais
m
[Musique]
f
m
je tiens
[Musique]
ok
une étude vient
[Musique]
tél
et
oui
[Musique]
le jazz ska
c
c'est
oh
avant
travaux
comment tu as trouvé là j'ai trouvé
magnifique bam a retrouvé très bien
d'accompagner way through belle reprise
à la barre et courageuse parce que c'est
du bon matériel
alors maintenant elle mais niant les
mecs qui vont faire tourner côté leurs
beats je vous demande
il est par ailleurs sap est très
dangereux édition on change de ton
on change de ton alors la moitié
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un [__] monde specta je me marre
un grand-père les langues dans la
chambre de son petit fils et son
petit-fils ils jouent à la console et
qu'est ce que tu fous un jouet mais tu
es fou et à 20 ans tu fais rien moi
quand j'avais ton âge tu dis ce qu'il
choisit j'étais au moulin rouge tous les
soirs ou moins rouge j'ai bu vais-je
danse et tripoter les filles à embrasser
les filles un peu ternie changement t il
vraiment debout sur la table ça la vraie
vie il ya un an il a impressionné trois
mois après derrière son petit fils
errant dans l'échangé petit fils il est
tuméfié de partout la lune et péter
déballeurs élabora cassidy qu'elle ça
fait mais baby j'ai fait exactement
comme tu m'as dit faisons la rouge j'ai
bien j'ai dansé debout sur la table les
pistes soit à pied tripoter des piges
il dit mais tu étais avec qui mais moi
j'étais avec des amis pourquoi tu étais
avec quito papilles si je comprends les
gîtes et les allemands
c'est un mec qui rentre chez lui il a un
canard dans mes bras et à sa femme qu'il
fallait sur le canapé il caresse etienne
à lille qui a vu chez une grosse truie
s'affiche à la porte de cause paraissait
pas une c'est pas une truie 5mp ta
gueule c'est pas le battre
le prochain narcisse gille m
il est d'origine marocaine voilà après
un arménien je dis maintenant à marocain
c'est plus une soirée d'humour c'est
l'onu il a fini deuxième au championnat
du monde de stand-up thierry ardisson le
présente comme le seul arabe qui a
réussi à faire et les etats-unis depuis
le 11-septembre comme quoi la vraie
humoriste terroristes à une si la presse
voilà c'est prêt oussama ben laden il a
failli faire un trapéziste vois ça s'est
pas joué à grand chose lui en tout cas
c'est promis il va vous faire marrer je
vous demande de faire un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour monsieur
mustapha el atrassi
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir pigalle
alors moi j'ai un nouveau spectacle qui
hérite au courant s'appelle lecture
maintenant je note les idées dans la
tête et je les raconte voix si ça marche
je très heureux d'être ici mais pour
être honnête j'aime pas beaucoup pigalle
eu ce que je supporte vraiment pas dans
ce quartier c'est les rabatteurs devant
les bars si c'est les mecs qui viennent
te dire qu'il faut aller voir des filles
nues à l'intérieur ils mettent des mecs
sont des trottoirs pour te dire viens
voir des filles à l'intérieur tu vois
mais ça donne pas du tout envie j'ai pas
si vous avez vu le profil des gars qui
est cette rabattre un petit régal grosse
doudoune de dents en or 1 ayant moins
légale il regarde 10 es tu veut baiser
frère l'a tout de suite non
[Musique]
en parlant de prostitution je pense que
bernard de la villardière devrait être
maire du 18e sais pas ce que vous en
pensez parce qu'on a beaucoup de plus
dans le quartier mais je voudrais
m'adresser aujourd'hui à anne hidalgo
maire de paris où elle a camera and il
faut renouveler les [__] c'est
important elles sont vieillissantes ah
non c'est pas possible vous avez alors
je vous donner un conseil pour
différencier une vieille d'une jeune put
ce qu'on se pose souvent la question ces
horaires comme on le sait c'est quoi le
déclic c'est très simple une jeune
pucelle va te dire pour 60 euros jeu
puisque tu veux une vieille [__] à va
dire pour 30 euros je fais ce que je
peux
on la garde
j'ai arrêté la bleue il ya pas longtemps
quel ennui
parler aux gens en temps réel et tout
c'est incroyable les gens sont ennuyeux
il a fait que j'arrête là club d'abord
pas pour des raisons de finances il ya
des gens qui avec la clope à pour la
santé un indice est trop cher et c'est
trop cher je pas si vous êtes au courant
mais en 2020 le paquet de clopes 10
euros 10 euros le paquet de clopes en
2020 ça continue bientôt quand roulera
un joint c'est le tabac qu'on effritera
sur le shit
[Applaudissements]
mon dealer et blanc
parce que monde a le droit à sa chance
mais les mauvais j'ai un dealer mauvais
ya des bons et des mauvais dans chaque
domaine mon dealer est à chier c'est il
veut parlant mot de passe déjà
ils devront trois grammy se prend pour
el chapo le nec
amputé des mots de passe des années 90
tous les trucs nuls tous les dealers ont
des mots de passe nulle s'est dit jean
en route je te ramène tes 3 dvd oh là là
on est intraçable
non j'ai j'ai changé dealer récemment
parce qu'il fallait que je me reprenne
fait que je reprenne ma vie en main et
s'est aussi passé par là je suis tombé
sur un dealer mais d'une violence c'est
à dire que j'étais au restaurant avec ma
mère pour mon anniversaire parce qu'on
se dit tout il fallait que je pécho de
labeur et ce nouveau gala que j'ai
jamais vue ils allaient venir aux restos
m'interrompt break ma mère tu vois le
gars arrive en scooter qui klaxonnent et
déjà il m'avait envoyé un seul message
j'étais pas bien premier message m'a
renvoyé dis moi combien il faut adresser
digicode j'arrive ici c'est une bagarre
où une livraison j'ai peur le gars il
arrive comme ça il me regarde pas
transition pas bonjour elle ou il ya la
mer derrière qui zieute comme ça et me
regarde et me dit première phrase que
jamais pu me regarde me dis que j'ai
tout j'ai tout
et moi je dis est tous plus loin il ya
des gens l'attaquant vient semer ici
discret voyez des gens qui peuvent le
reconnaître il me regarde et me dit tu
sais quoi environ 100 bats les couilles
on la république à plein de gens qu'est
ce qu'il fait il sort une sacoche comme
ça ils l'ouvrent et y pose un plaid il
avait un pl est dedans il a posé par
terre comme les stands au bled au souk
turin j'ai regardé je digresse des
ray-ban y adhérer bonne sinon le gérant
chez en tulle et ses paillettes szpiner
m'a regardé et m'a dit guette szpiner
journée
j'ai tout fait et c'était vraiment une
belle anecdote que je leur racontais
surtout la fin était belge avait jamais
rencontré ce mec là il remonte sur son
scooter comme ça et il me regarde avec
beaucoup d'émotion comme ça je me
rappellerai toute ma vie de sa dernière
phrase il m'a regardé et m'a dit d'y
acquérir je le rappelle 1
le cribiq formidable c'est un plaisir
pour moi d'être ici merci à vous
mercredi et jeudi
toi mon commune henri ben on s'est
croisés mais ces croisés il est alors il
est
assis ses bières et bien d'autres cas et
alors je vais vous dire un truc j'ai
rarement le trac et à voir
laurent baffie thierry ardisson qui me
regarde pendant un sketch
sérieux cadoret y en a d e k n'aurait
franchement cette offre bat mon jeu
merci beaucoup mais vraiment je suis
pourtant vous êtes lui
va commencer avec les marionnettes du
pdis ouais en fait j'ai quitté ma ville
de tours pour venir faire du show
business et c'est vrai que ma famille
avait un peu peur est extrêmement de
détraqués je leur dis non pas du tout et
je joue je joue je jouais le premier
truc on m'a fait faire effectivement il
ya quelques années c'était les premières
parties des marionnettes du pénis cdma
qui en fait sont des figures avec leur
sexe voilà qui serait donc impossible en
chine par exemple mais là ils ont pris
les danois pour un espèce de bordel et
et font ce que tu veux car en peut-elle
la vocation quand tu avais à londres
ouais j'ai eu cette chance j'étais
interdit de sortie scolaire en fait
j'étais trop dépendantes a vu un mec qui
disait des cheveux longs pour y glisser
n'importe quoi sur scène way you stand
up et tu te dis c'est ça que je veux
faire en fait est une fois de plus très
bien informé en fait j'avais pas
grenelle dans les musées tous à une
sortie scolaire donc ça je m'en foutais
à la rigueur ça m'arrangeait sauf
comparé à londres et le stand-up
n'existe pas en france et là on est dans
un bar et moi je passe ma vie à faire
des vannes au moins quatre c'était un
truc vous les mecs ont des perruques ou
faut de l'argent un réseau est là il ya
un gars qu'une petite chemise un peu
froissé et tout est bien effet ce que
j'ai toujours fait ce qu on l'applaudît
on rigole et tout et c'est ce qui
s'appelait le stand-up on connaissait
pas en france j'ai dit je rentre en
france je prends un micro et je
m'adresse aux gens et et la merde et je
fais de la merde elle et j'ai commencé à
l'âge de 11 ans donc ça fait déjà 21 ans
que je fais des blagues en fait en fait
un tour spectacle ce que tu veux
maintenant c'est
80% à 100 bourses en impro quoi ouais je
m'interdis en fait de faire le même
spectacle chaque soir donc j'aimerais
j'invite les gens à à repayer une place
et le lendemain parce que je me suis
promis ça je leur dis aux gens je veux
je te jure que je pense mais peut-être
différent chaque soir on me surprend le
moi même parce que je me gêne depuis du
touré cité satanique
et j'aime 80 lecture alors
comment ça va techniquement
affectivement je suis à un coeur à
prendre kerry
c'est d'amitié est ce que vous devez
faire
pourquoi ces progressions ne suis pas un
chien malade sa voie de changer quand
même des noëls à l'elysée tous à nous
moi j'en ai fait j'en ai fait que deux
des noix comment c'était mais nous on
veut savoir parce qu'on n'y a jamais été
a fait quoi quel code oui fidéliser
ça fait serait pas champion oui j'ai
chanté pour les enfants des liaisons
avec rafa alors j'ai chanté à l'elysée
c'était l'époque de jacques chirac par
contre raffarin c'est à l'opéra à
l'opéra ouais quoi tu as chanté à
l'opéra oui oui métro opéra
c'est pourquoi c'était pour les enfants
10 mois et de matignon et raffarin était
là j'étais bien dans notre dame quand
même
[Applaudissements]
éloquent nouvel agent quelque chose de
la lune tu es un nouvel album qui
raconte un petit peu des moments de des
moments de ma vie petit peu plus calme
que ce que j'ai pu faire auparavant à la
gorge été calmés un peu c'est un peu
calmé la tv et novateur le fait que
demain vous appartient ça me rappelle
mon l'émission la nuit nous appartient
mais je ne porterai pas maintenant
maintenant police ne fait pas que de la
télé elle a fait du cinéma avec la zone
et smaïn oui c'est vrai je veux tu nous
en parle qu'en super non mais c'est quoi
ce film avec elle le plus connu et mal
j'ai rien infinera des algériens avec
l'auris
bonjour savoir plus et ça non c'était un
film un film d'action algérien toute
première production indépendante
algérienne était top c'était là leur
premier film d'action où le héros est
algérien et que voilà on embrasse
l'algérie du coup moi parce qu'on leur
ait de problème avec averses tu me
regardes à l'algérie
célibataire
[Musique]
des tentacules
touchant
paris et tu ne peux pas
[Musique]
après
com
[Musique]
ce
[Applaudissements]
champagne haye
tpiy
havas
[Musique]
l'état
et voilà madame monsieur c'était un
samedi soir pigalle
j'espère vous avez passé une bonne
soirée de la nouvelle aile rigide
dire tout ce qu'ils vous ont peiné ce
soir par l'apparition il avait et
laconi des airs pop et marque mettra
buteur sackmann le dresseur de rats
mustapha el atrassi car à morgane et son
cabaret et vous pouvez revenir très fort
toutes les danseuses de l'année
oui
mais selon ma fille est monsieur
nous avons regardé cellulite passer une
peine 30 soir
or nous n'avons
infligée pour une station de métro
entouré de dix prix égal
edel minuit votre sentiment une boîte de
nuit rigal
[Musique]
est-ce que tu passes une bonne soit je
passe une super soirée tout alors
j'avais les larmes aux yeux parce que je
me suis dit thierry c'est ce que tu
voulais c'est ton rêve d'une mission de
nouveaux élèves tu sais quand tu es
vieux tu veux faire tout ce que tu as
rêvé dans ta vie avant de mourir donc là
je me dis [__] mais c'est exactement
ça que j'ai mal en faire une tous les
mois pourquoi il fait pas tous les mois
je sais pas il faut trouver des gens
comme eric antoine les gens tu vois
britannique et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais 1 pouces bleus